oui c'est bonjour et merci d'être en
direct ce matin maître mot sur rt france
alors on s'attendait à passer un été
tranquille visiblement ça ne sera pas le
cas puisque emmanuel macron va prendre
la parole lundi soir une crise sanitaire
qui dure la fin du mandat aussi qui
approche peut te dis moi initialement
d'ailleurs le chef de l'état devait
présenter le cap qu'il compte garder ces
prochains mois et puis là le conseil
scientifique
qui affiche des recommandations à votre
avis est-ce qu emmanuel macron va suivre
cette fois ci le conseil scientifique ou
va-t-il continuer à faire cavalier seul
alors cette intervention a beaucoup
d'enjeu pour emmanuel macron on pensait
pouvoir passer un été et un retour à la
vie normale grâce à la vaccination mais
finalement on s'aperçoit à cause d'une
brillante d'état les prévisions nous
informe d'une reprise de l'épidémie
à la fin du mois de juillet ou à la
sortie de l'été donc y voir une reprise
dès la question sanitaire dans l'agenda
politique alors que macro emmanuel m'a
comblé reprendre la main et notamment
sur le sujet des retraites aborder des
thématiques qui soient davantage
économiques qui sont plutôt sombres
encore il va être en fait contraints de
continuer sur des thématiques plus tôt
sanitaires donc cette intervention est
là elle à avoir deux effets la première
est de fixer le cas tranché ou pas s'il
ya une bad à la fois mener le combat sur
le sanitaire et en même temps mené des
réformes économiques et portait des
grandes réformes et des totems pour
continuer à préparer la campagne
présidentielle
en incarnant un président réformateur et
le second le second volet c'est
reprendre la main sur une séquence
médiatique qui était plutôt à son
désavantage
à la sortie des régionales avec les
faibles scores de la république en marge
donc ça lui permet de reprendre la main
sur débat public sur l'agenda médiatique
et de peser de tout son poids dans les
décisions qui vont être apprend sur la
question du conseil scientifique
emmanuel macron a comme vous l'avez
rappelé dans votre reportage parfois
suivis parfois non les recommandations
ce qui est important d'avoir encaissé
que le conseil scientifique porte un
conseil qui est scientifique et
d'avantagés qui est principalement
centrée sur la question sanitaire
le rôle du politique et en particulier
des manuels macron c'est de concilier à
la fois les enjeux économiques les
enjeux sanitaires et l'acceptabilité
sociale des mesures
emmanuel macron est confronté à un
double problème c'est que globalement le
taux de vaccination est insuffisant pour
éviter une reprise de l'épidémie et
atteindre l'immunité collective et dans
le même temps il doit respecter deux
promesses fondamentale celle qu'il a
tenue en décembre qui n'auraient pas de
vaccination obligatoire et la seconde
qui ont plus été rappelé par olivier
révérend assez récemment c'est que la
vaccination
c'était une protection à 100 %
contre 1 re confinement peut pas avoir
une vaccination obligatoire pour
l'ensemble de la population
il ya la question sur les soignants qui
à être une subtilité un peu particulière
il va avoir du mal à pouvoir imposer de
nouvelles mesures restrictives que ça
fait depuis un an les français subissent
des confinement des couvre-feux et un
espèce de yo yo dans la privation de
leur liberté est en fait finalement il
lui reste uniquement le volet incitatif
de la vaccination et on ne sait pas si
cela va suffire à faire face à la crise
c'est un jeu d'équilibriste auquel on
doit s'attendre
justement le président qui est un petit
peu prise en étau aussi avec l'opinion
publique puisque on le voit bien après
le deuxième confinement par exemple il y
avait eu beaucoup de critiques parce que
le président n'avait pas confiné plutôt
parce qu'il n'avait pas suivi l avis du
conseil scientifique aujourd'hui les
français veulent passer un été
tranquille donc qu'ils s'attendent pas
vraiment ils ne veulent pas de nouvelles
restrictions sanitaires
tout à fait d'autant qu'il ya d une
projection de l'institut pasteur qui
montrent que s'il devait y avoir de
nouvelles restrictions généralisée il
n'aurait pas de différence sur la
propagation d'épidémies
entre prendre des restrictions de
liberté pour l'ensemble de la population
ou uniquement pour les personnes non
vaccinées
donc en termes d'efficacité il faudrait
plutôt préconisé un passani terre et
avoir des restrictions uniquement sur
les personnes vaccinées mais dans le
même temps sa pause imprévue de rupture
d'égalité un problème on pourrait
ajouter à la fracture sociale et à la
fracture territoriale une fracture
sanitaire puisque les territoires et les
populations qui sont le moins vacciner
qui souffre le plus du cobp ils sont en
réalité des populations qui sont les
plus en difficulté socialement et
économiquement
donc on rajouterait encore une rupture
et une fracture sanitaire sur les
différentes fractures donc un climat
social qui pourrait être difficile
d'autant que la crise économique devrait
toucher une partie des français à la
rentrée
et dans le même temps il peut pas être
dans l'inaction parce que la crise
sanitaire oprean et son rôle c'est de
protéger les français dans cette
équation très compliquée emmanuel macron
il a un atout
c'est l'avis sur le marché d'un vaccin
français le vaccin de sanofi
qui devrait faire baisser les réticences
du vaccin essaie de convaincre une
partie un peu plus importante de la
population puisque c'est un vaccin qui
est plutôt traditionnelle en termes de
méthodologie et qui est français donc en
fait emmanuel macron il va devoir tout
faire pour inciter au maximum à la
vaccination pour augmenter le taux de
vaccination sans pour autant être trop
directif en terme aux obligations
vaccinales
mais en même temps prendre toutes les
mesures possibles en termes de tests pcr
qui pourrait devenir payant de passes
annie terre qui peut être un peu plus
discriminant en termes d'accès aux
différents services et commerces pour
réviser ses ya passé de passer outre la
reprise épidémique sans avoir à prendre
de nouvelles mesures de restriction de
liberté importante et sans avoir à
obliger la population est vaccinée de
force
dernière question très rapidement on a
vu aussi le sujet concernant justement
les déclarations de clément boon jean
yves le drian cadets avant hier son
secrétaire d'état qui incite et
justement les français à se rendre en
espagne qui demande aux français de ne
pas se rendre en espagne à cause du
mariage
delta est ce que ces déclarations voilà
ambiguë en fait on dit le contraire et
puis on dîne enfin tout et son contraire
c'est l'illustration de la confusion qui
règne au sein même du gouvernement
c'est l'illustration d'un changement de
paradigme
si le fait de bloquer les frontières et
d'éviter les sorties territoire était
cohérente
lorsqu'on avait ni vaccin et des tests
en quantité insuffisante
la position de jean yves le drian et
plus cohérente sur sur cet aspect la
rampe en espagne en fait une reprise de
l'épidémie notamment chez les jeunes
parce qu'ils n'ont pas eu accès à la
vaccination et le danger c'est que qu'on
est globalement beaucoup de jeunes qui
aillent dans dans des bars et dans des
soirées en espagne et au retour des
vacances d'ici mines le nouveau variant
d'état aux quatre coins de la france
mais cette thématique là et cette
problématique là on devrait ne plus la
voir si les personnes sont vaccinées
lorsqu'elles partent en vacances donc la
position la plus cohérente c'est
davantage celle de jean yves le drian et
s inscrit dans une logique on doit
pouvoir concilier une reprise de
l'activité économique
donc de pouvoir consommer pouvoir partir
en vacances et en même temps une
protection sanitaire
efficace grâce au vaccin merci beaucoup
brighi c'est d'avoir répondu à nos
questions ce matin je rappelle que vous
êtes secrétaire générale adjointe de
think tank le millénaire